on va parler maintenant de la faire koh
lanta et la renaud revel qui va venir
nous dire tout ce qui s'est passé au lit
je vous le dis et des choses folles qui
sont passés dans vos sur cette histoire
et on a d'ailleurs la vidéo denis
brunner qui vient de sortir qui s'est
expliqué sur cette affaire regardez
petit récap de ce qui s'est passé
que s'est il vraiment passé dans la
sphère kolontar dans la nuit de mercredi
à jeudi une candidate candide renard
auraient été victimes d'agressions
sexuelles de la part d'un autre candidat
est dit la société de production décide
alors d'arrêter rapidement le tournage
au bout du cinquième jour le dimanche
candide de retour en france décide de
porter plainte à son arrivée à
l'aéroport quand haïti il est placé en
garde à vue lundi dès sa sortie de
l'avion
l'agresseur présumé est relâché au bout
de quatre heures de garde à vue
l'affairé renvoyée au parquet de nancy
nancy ville dédié un forain de 33 ans
marié et bientôt père de deux enfants
une famille respectée et sans histoire
selon marcel campion
aujourd'hui nouveau rebondissement la
radio rmc a dévoilé la version de la
plaignante
jlp réveillé dans la nuit alors qu'il
brille et est en train de s'embrasser et
de pratiquer des attouchements sont
nettement depuis quelques jours les
langues se délient dans var matin un
candidat de cette saison annulée fait
part de sa déception
ils ont tué mon rêve j'étais bien je
savais que j'allais gagner car cette
aventure était taillé pour moi je suis
en colère
alors fallait-il arrêter le tournage est
annulé cette saison de koh lanta de
leurs mots qui continue et les records
sur son débat alors renaud revel nous a
rejoint vous êtes au jdd rhône où vous
êtes un ami en plus de la famille tp
c'est que la télé vous êtes aux côtés de
julien courbet et c'est vrai qu'il ya
encore des rebondissements dans cette
affaire koh lanta puisque ce matin les
cinq témoins ont été entendus par la
police
est-ce qu'ils ont confirmé au contredit
les propos de candide
non ils ont affirmé ils sont confiantes
et les propos de des divisions d'accord
du diverses ont déjà auditionné devant
sur place vous avez toutes leurs
auditions de cas ont été enregistrés sur
place d'accord donc les policiers ils
ont totalement les images des auditions
il aux images qui ont été tournées
lui-même et des images sur tenter la
nuit toutes les deux heures la
production sur place film est accro des
rushes ya beaucoup d images et d images
ont été filmées dans les trois jours qui
ont précédé l'incident en question parce
qu'ils ont voulu ici on me voir un peu
comment quelles étaient les relations
entre le entre elle et lui
mais les cinq protagonistes ont confirmé
en tout cas la thèse des tuyaux te ni
l'avocat de candide ce que l'avocat de
kindu
dit que ce sont des faits news et que et
que ces témoins n'existe pas enfin non
pas comment ils ont été auditionnés ils
ont quand même couché c'est sûr comme
des procès verbaux
ils ont été tous les hôtes où les uns et
les autres et visiblement ça corrobore
la thèse initiale dans laquelle il se
serait passé peu de chose en tout cas
c'était juste est-ce que vous pensez que
la production a eu raison d'arrêter le
tournage de koh lanta ou pas vous en
euros d'elle bien sûr on penser oui mais
là n'est pas le choix pourquoi dès lors
que sur place ont lancé être un portrait
de la situation apocalyptique et vont
parler d'agression sexuelle et continue
d précédent qui avait vu quand même avec
la sphère ben ammar et autres il n'avait
pas le choix on comprend à l'excellent
joubert et stéphane courbit entendant ça
quand même un à dix mille kilomètres
il n'avait pas d'autre choix que
d'annuler après effectivement que sur
place c'est très mal géré ce qui était
le cas en revanche si je n'ai pas le
choix alors via rmc qui a dévoilé la
version des faits de candide renard donc
la jeune fille raconte que les
candidates dormir à même le sol etc et
dis donc le garçon avait comme habitude
de s'allonger entre les filles pour les
réchauffer c'est un garçon qui est très
grand qui est très balèze voilà et elle
dit et voilà les filles ont dit on avait
l'habitude voilà de se mettre à côté des
dix parce que pour ce pour se réchauffer
elle affirme qu'elle a été réveillé dans
la nuit edith en train de l'embrasser et
de pratiquer des attouchements sous ses
vêtements c'est ce qu'elle a dit elle
aura alors repoussé à plusieurs reprises
sa main elle aurait ensuite quitté
l'abri où le gros passer la nuit
elle assure s'être confiées à d'autres
candidats puis à des membres de l'équipe
des tournages et bien sûr et dit ni
complètement les faits le garçon est ce
qui a surpris les policiers de la paf
que j'ai eu au téléphone à roissy c'est
que 1 ils ont été surpris par la
rapidité l'intervalle de
l'interpellation à windows heures de
garde à vue comme ça hop un avion c'est
très très rare quand et surtout de la
vie du dossier il a rien dedans et
surtout ils ont demandé en tout cas et
qu'une confrontation à roissy et la
jeune fille en question a refusé la
confrontation déjà d'accord il l'a
réclamé on aurait pu savoir un petit box
et il paraît que candide voilà refuse à
quoi une fondation avec quelqu'un ce qui
pose un problème quand même des choses
dans le dossier irlandais truction dû
gérer le niger est ouverte
comme vous savez ce qui pose un problème
pour le cette prod parce que tout va
sortir maintenant les images et les
témoignages ils vont sortir toutes les
images tout l'été c'est donc tout était
si oui alors qu'ils pensent qu'ils
auraient pas dû arrêter le tournage que
ceux qui pensent qu'il aurait dû arrêter
oui battue non moi je pense
qu'effectivement il fallait l'arrêter
demain je vais aller un petit pot de la
trétoire ahmed tf1 jours
vraiment vraiment aux gens et de penser
à l'argent c'est quelle émission dans
laquelle il eu des blessés dans
lesquelles il eu un mort un médecin se
souvient mais maintenant une tentative
de viol il ya un moment
or si c'est vrai il faudrait peut-être
penser à arrêter cette émission qui
commence vraiment à devenir scabreuses
et dur comme n'importe quelle émission
aurait été arrêté c'est tellement une
machine à cash que malgré les morts et
le viol chaque année les prix en
revanche le mort le médecin
une émission dans laquelle maintenant
clairement foot qui sont mort d'un arrêt
cardiaque sur arrêter le foot va c'est
un divertissement laquelle j'aurais
juste quand même dire un petit truc
parce que renault a dit que la
production était vraiment appris les
choses très au sérieux puisque le
producteur de ce koh lanta c'est le
producteur qui avait fait d'europe c'est
julien mahé exactement et c'est le
producteur également qui a eu qui a eu
la la saison avec voilà voilà le lot
jusqu'où ira la main donc voila mais tu
peux pas dire ça en l'occurrence le
médecin séné médias qui en sont
responsables
tellement on a chargé jour après jour et
c'est ce qu'il a lu dans les médias jour
après jour qu'ils ont fait péter les
plombs je connais tu ne connaissais bien
oui mais pourrait pas supporté que son
honneur on vient y aura-t-il de jardy
congrès la première
combien y aura-t-il un drame dans cette
boîte traduction arrêt pour normand ça
prend des gens qui furent des jeux
d'aventuré sur le kouter sur fort boyard
il faut fort boyard n'y a jamais eu de
problème à rien on est bien d'accord
voilà la logique revenir sur l'oeuf ou
de la faire oui parce que je trouve avec
tout le respect rhône au rhin mais vous
confondez un tout petit peu je trouve la
médiatisation qui est très fort d'un des
deux côtés en l'occurrence du côté des
dix présomption d'innocence total alors
que la victime présumée elle aussi se
tait globalement mieux son avocat lui
relate les faits c'est tout mais oui
mais oui ce que je veux dire c'est que
il est beaucoup trop tôt parce que du
côté de la victime présumée
on dit qu'on a quand même un argument
mais l'effort imaginons qu'ils aient une
en tout cas une confrontation entre les
deux protagonistes neil des leurs
feuilles de l'avion ça a été réglé en un
quart d'heure diato sort était réglé ses
problèmes connus le froid de la surprise
bonjour est juste qu on voit la réaction
de denis brogniart regarder bonjour à
tous je suis rentré aujourd'hui à paris
je voulais simplement vous dire quelques
mots
d'abord j'ai une pensée pour tous les
aventuriers de cette saison qui a été
arrêté je voulais vous dire aussi que
dès que j'ai été prévenu de la situation
au petit matin du cinquième jour j'ai
très vite compris que je ne pourrais pas
continuer à présenter cette saison la
décision de la production de suspendre
l'émission a été partagé par tous des
équipes techniques et f1 qui comme moi
ont été marqués par cet événement un
grand merci du fond du coeur à tous ceux
nombreux qui m'ont envoyé des messages
chaleureux et puis je peux vous
l'annoncer koh lanta reviendra bientôt
sur tf1
alors oui prévu des aléas juste on peut
pas j'entends ce que vous dites renault
mais on peut pas dire si la la la
présumée victime avait rencontré son
présumé agresseur se serait réglé c'est
pas vrai parce que d'abord un peut pas
forcer une présumée victime avoir envie
de retrouver son agresseur pardon à mes
un face à face avec un violeur ou un
présumé violeur sait jamais très
agréable je l'assumé présumé attention
rien dire et je peux comprendre que la
jeune femme n'est pas forcément c'est
que se retrouvent début août j'ai shooté
et inversement mais ne peut pas dire que
le oui qui se fout qu'ils ne se voient
règles et valérie blais en partie pour
personne le garçon si ces faits sont
faux si lui aussi des institutions
médicales
il a une famille aussi alors la jeune
fille ont fui mais voilà à sa place
c'est sait si les faits sont avérés
c'est vrai que c'est très grave et on
comprend qu'elle veuille pas la
confrontation mais le garçon se met
aussi à sa place si c'est pas vrai si
c'est faux le garçon une famille
forcément lui il a eu droit jeudi pour
défendre une loi qu'il attend la boîte
de prod et f1 pour le coup et que le
pacs est justement c'est ce qui est
arrivé avant il était obligé de le faire
et c'est ma préparation peut nous
arrêter fois pour une fois c'est la
seule et bonne décision
l'argent qu'il n'avait pas le choix et
bien-être pas dire que c'est pour le
pognon et qu' il était de leur faute ait
eu des morts commerçants du cha cha qui
profite profite le crime et moi ce qui
m'interpelle c'est pourquoi elle aurait
dit ça si j'ai réussi
kim pour qu'elle est quelle est la
raison qu'elles auraient alors on nous
dit je vous dis on nous dit elle alors
je dis pas ce que je sais c'est une
histoire de fou parce que si je vous dis
là la raison qui est invoquée vous
renouveau 8,6 l'insee que tu l'avocat en
tout cas d'eddy pillot c'est que elle
elle pensait qu'elle allait être éliminé
dans lesquels avaient besoin de la voix
des 10 et donc quel aurait été le voir
pendant la nuit pourrait essayer voilà
d'avoir sa voix pour ne pas être
éliminés sais pas
alors il reste à vérifier tout ça bien
sûr le mot de la fin
c'est cette histoire va se régler
comment maintenant chose où il y avait
un combi un compromis qui était possible
il ya encore avant-hier maintenant c'est
fini
donc là maintenant une action de série
tous vers le hockey tu vas aller au bout
donc oui ça a promis d'aller très vite
un dizaine de jours on sera peu près
dans une dizaine de jours on saura peu à
peu près où laura symbole histoire bien
sûr ma salle à faire des dégâts parce
que tf1 est très pénalisés
financièrement la beauté production est
également l'un ça va laisser des traces
et puissant entache l'image de quand
même de cette école en table